hi i promised myself that i wouldn't
play this game again
unless someone paid me to do it
[Applause]
so i'd like to thank alienware for
sponsoring this video
alienware the ultimate gaming pc
it's the only choice alienware was kind
enough to send me over
this chair which i imagine is very
aerodynamic
and the new aurora r11 which is their
latest gaming pc
also aerodynamic among other things so
as i play this game keep in mind
that i'm being paid to do this but thank
you to alienware for helping out
go to alienware.com to customize your pc
today
let's get into it i love this game i'm
so glad i have this opportunity to play
it again
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
where am i i forgot how to play
i forgot completely how to play how do i
how do i shoot oh my god
okay hi hey how you doing i literally
forgot how to play
i've got about 400 meters less than 400
meters to go to the summit of this
mountain i think it goes straight to
1000 i'm not 100 sure
where am i going oh crap oh i forgot
about that
i forgot about that i forgot about that
i forgot about that
i forgot about it i'm going backwards
i'm going the wrong way
oh no no excellent
i'm not i've forgotten completely how to
play
no okay
i remember okay
oh my god oh my god oh my god where am i
going
[Music]
now
the alienware battle stations are
powered by 10th generation
intel core i7 processors this is what
the intel logo looks like in case you
forgot
there it is that's what's inside notice
how smooth the game runs
i'm not gonna go that way
i have this stupid cheat and i'm gonna
use it i've completely forgotten how to
play all of the coordination
that i built up over the the arduous
journey
no this wrong i'm fine i'm fine
this is fine yeah all of the skill all
the calluses
that i've put upon my hands are long
gone and all that's left is the memory
of the hate
the memory of the burning hatred inside
my soul how did i do this before
how did i do how did i do this before i
let go
no yes all right fine we're gonna yeah i
just gotta tap
just gotta tap and i know
this is cheating so why am i even
remotely getting
upset about anything nope oh my god
oh my god every time every time every
time
alienware is the industry leader in
design
innovation and the latest technology and
ultimate performance
their products are designed and
engineered for gamers
i hate how smooth
this game runs i hate how
comfortable i am in this one of a kind
no one of a kind
alienware gaming chair truly is the
pinnacle of
comfort i have legitimately forgotten oh
my god
i've legitimately forgotten how to play
i've forgotten entirely how to play this
wonderful game i thought i was done with
this it took me so
long that's the piece it took me so
long i was cheating
oh no
that's fine i don't know how i always do
this i come back
and i just absolutely
devastate my hopes
just all hopes gone all possibility of
achievement
gone no come back i'm never gonna get
past the bees again
i'm never going to get there's i'm gonna
get past the bees
i am very good at what i do
no yeah no yeah
no yeah i've never had this kind of head
support before
not in the hole i'm going this way now
i'm going to make it
it's fine
look at these fun bees oh my god i
cannot believe this
this is the worst this is the best this
is going great
going terribly i hate it and i hate this
uh why am i not using my boost why did i
go where i know it
just don't hit the bee i know it's a big
rotund
buttocks very all right so
i know i just said don't hit the b but
that was the moment when you should have
hit the b
yes oh my god wizard wizard wizard
wizard with the pogo
not wizard bad bad wizard evil wizard
evil wizard with a not great wizard
wonderful wizard
wizard of oz oh my god i'm no
oh my god get that oh
okay it's fine oh my god oh my god no no
no
okay this is the one oh yeah
that's how you do no this is not how you
do
it yes it's gonna be here
it's gonna be here all right we're gonna
go here and then over here
yes just like that ah where am i where
am i where my
fine i'm making it through all of my
skill
in my blood and my bones ah
yes yes that's how you do it
that's how you do it this is how i'm
back on top baby
back on top just got to let it do its
thing
oh my god can you oh my god brain damage
brain damage brain damage
brain damage so much brain damage so
much brain damage
so my oh my god
i'm just gonna go up i'm just gonna go
up i'll just go around it that's what i
did
that's what i do that that's all i need
to do i just go around it
i don't need to do anything you're
talking about i don't need to obey your
instructions
where am i going no i'm fine if i let go
all right we're fine fine okay and flip
this is so good for me oh my god
no not like this not it's fine why was i
worried
i don't know why were you worried why am
i even trying to do it that way when
clearly the correct answer is no
what am i doing with my life what am i
doing
so scary okay this is how we do what
what what don't give me this crap oh
yeah i can hold on to that all
day baby where am i land on a wheel i'm
not that wheel
i am so good at games
and especially this one you know all
this skill is really going to apply
later in my life when i have
hopes and dreams and you know i don't
think that every
waking moment is pain and torture my
life isn't just full of agony
stabbing into my brain
powered by intel there we go i'm
going to grab on no i am not
yes i will now do that okay
that's how we do nice oh there was a
ceiling there i didn't know about
there was a ceiling there that i didn't
know about there was a ceiling there
that i did not know about i didn't even
see that
i touch you i touch you again
and i touch you for the last time i am
one with
the where am i uh oh my god
okay we're fine oh my god oh
no okay all right
we're fine here i go i'm going for it
no no no
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
it's just a game
whatever i need to relax
more yeah i'll go back up i'll go back
up this mountain
going back up is good it's a good thing
it's a great thing actually
it's another chance for me to see the
worlds that i so enjoyed the first time
i went through this
there we go that's what i was going for
look i'm
really good at this game i'm so
good at games in general just all over
the place
i'm so good at games everyone knows this
it's basically a uh
a talking point among many social
circles is just how good at games i am
brought to you by alienware you know
people often refer to me as
the king you know they say that about me
but
heavyweights the crown you know as uh
people have been quoted as saying about
being you know when
the the king and wears a crown i can't
even get past this part again
yeah i've made it
oh every time oh these
bees these bees these bees these bees
beat the bees
beat the base the i hate
so strongly but not
ah
god just give me past the bees the bee
the bee
[Music]
[Applause]
the b the b
the b is my power word it's the word
that gives me strength
inspires me to go further farther higher
faster better stronger
no one can stop me once i find the bee
have you ever found a bee i think not
for if you did you would not know and if
you don't know how good you did
no one knows no one did no one's done no
one will
so says being so says me a b
c deeper then there's three
take me under the umbrella
beast i will see myself
to greece all will know the epic
three please fleece
[Music]
i've done it i am the best that ever did
anything
forever in the history of
literally ever oh my god please don't
end it like thusly
don't end it like thusly okay it's all
good
i will make this okay okay can you jump
through it wait can you jump over it
oh my god i made it oh my god i made it
what is what is the point of this
oh what do you do corn cob oh lizard
tale oh how it wails
the sordid adventure of the tale the
beast it hails
oh it sails look out for this
the mighty tail i'm careful careful
careful careful my head
head damage it's okay i made it okay
i'm gonna throw up i'm gonna throw up
alienware also sent me
a desk a really nice desk but a very
large desk
now see me as a human being i need very
simple things
i could get by and i have gotten by with
a kitchen
chair fresh my desk chair and i've done
that and so long as it's a
table that can bear weight and it's a
few slugs of these
slammers here you know that's all i've
ever needed at a table but they they
kindly sent me
a a desk but it is downstairs
because it literally cannot fit up here
so that's in my kitchen now
it's very nice all right cool
i think i'm good there i think i'm good
there hey listen
thanks alienware for sponsoring this
video and subjecting me to the horrors
that is pogo stuck
i've made it another 50 meters
[Music]
good
excellent thank you and if alienware
decides to sponsor me again you will see
another episode and so long as people
keep paying me i will keep playing
all right thank you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you